the objective of this talk really is
just to teach a little bit about I've
shot
it's really level 100
it's not going to go into depth on the
language talk about c-sharp the
evolution of the language where that's
going how you see it changing where some
of the features are coming from and
really look at whether f-sharp might
actually be a better fit for you for the
types of programs you're writing today
why it might be a better fit how to help
you make a decision whether it's worth
investing time even looking at the
language and I'm hoping at the end of it
I've at least encouraged you to spend a
few hours maybe over the next few weeks
trying out the language playing with it
and just making that decision yourself
so just a bit about me my name is Isaac
Abraham I've been using C sharp and
dotnet what since don't know 1.0 so
almost 20 years now and using a sharp
for the last five or six years I'm from
London live in Germany now though I'm
the founder of CIT we're a company to do
F sharp consulting training development
and also yeah MVP these days for a sharp
in terms of my background I suspect it's
somewhat similar to many of you here in
that I've been doing C shop development
WPF silverlight asp.net MVC web forms
console applications and I went through
the whole thing of learning about solid
anyone know what solid is just yeah okay
if you have you test-driven development
unit testing those sorts of things
design patterns all of that so I'm
hoping that what I talk to about today
you won't see it is coming from sort of
an ivory tower perspective that someone
who's actually been writing c-sharp for
many years and I sort of started using
f-sharp and everything I'm telling you
that today is based on that sort of
experience and perspective why am I
really giving this talk oftentimes
you'll see people talk about something
they're really passionate about and it
can sometimes be difficult to understand
what their own motivation is for me the
reason why I use F sharp isn't really
f-sharp it's a means to an end the real
reason why use F sharp is because I am
passionate about writing quality
software so I like the idea that I can
release code that I feel confident about
that I know what it's been doing that I
feel that I was able to deliver a good
solution for my customers on top of that
I'm passionate about writing on net I'm
assuming that many of you here are using
dotnet in some way shape or form today
and donate core so I believe that that
dotnet core is a really really great
place particularly today to be writing
software and on top of that I think if
you're writing on dotnet court f-sharp
is a fantastic language so it's think of
it from the top down rather than from
the bottom up I'm not using f-sharp for
the sake of it but as a means to an end
to write high quality software what I'm
not going to do today is show you all of
the features of f-sharp so often times
you'll have seen talks and you can look
them up on YouTube or probably at NDC
hear that go through all the great
features of a sharp that either a
slightly different from c-sharp that
aren't in c-sharp and and so on so
people will talk about active patterns
and type providers and so on and so
forth but I don't think that's a
particularly effective way to actually
to show people why they might want to
use F sharp more often than I it's just
what I've seen all these features
yeah that sounds interesting but how
does it all come together
why is it so why would I want to give up
a language that I'm really good at that
I can use in second nature go through
the pain of learning something from
scratch so I'm not really going to do
that today it's probably a bit different
to some of the talks I give where I'm
sort of coding for most of it most of
this will be demos a couple of demos and
mostly slides to be honest what I will
tell you is there's one slide here which
is how do I really get to the secret and
the answer of what F sharp is and this
is really it I don't think I can show
you all the features today and you know
get a leave today and say yeah that
looks cool but I'm not going to start
using it tomorrow so the real thing is
try it out for yourself
I'm going to show you some things today
that might encourage you and hopefully
build up a bit of trust as to why you
can do a shop while you can use it how
you can use it but the truth is at the
end of the day you're gonna have to make
that decision of whether you want to
invest a bit of time in learning the
language as well and seeing if it fits
for you I would also say I think
oftentimes particularly with c-sharp and
I'll talk about this a bit later that we
see there's more more features in the
language and as I've started using a
shop more I've realized it's not
actually about the number of features
you have but it's the right mix of
features so it's equally important as
what features you do have there's what
ones you don't have in the language as
well and I'll give you some examples of
that as how some features actually
there's a tension between them and that
if you add one feature in it diminishes
the the impact of another one what I
really want to do is talk about how F
shot makes me feel from an emotional
point of view why it works for our
company how we've benefited from it and
and why you might want to do it so not
so much on the deep dive technical level
but more at high level just the quick
show of hands so I get an understanding
of who what you guys are your background
is who here is doing any f sharp today
or looked at it at all in production
okay good C sharp or visual basic that
map yeah pretty much everyone here
anyone who's doing software development
not on dotnet okay what was that
C ok straight C excellent any other ones
JavaScript Python okay cool
good good good so what I'm really gonna
focus on for the next 150 minutes or so
is what is isn't functional programming
trying to spell some myths tell you a
bit more about the language why you want
to be trying it and importantly how you
can actually get started so I'm gonna
just fire up a demo which I should have
really started beforehand I'd love to do
it now so unfortunately because I'm a
bit of a cheapskate I'm running this
demo on on the free is your service
which means that sometimes it takes a
minute or so to start out so what I'm
going to show you we'll leave it until
it starts it's basically a web
application that is written in a shop
it's hosted on this year it's running in
asp.net core dotnet core 3 and writing
with reacts react may react Redux and
Java scripts as well so once the zero
warms up this site we should be able to
see it
it doesn't start then I'll skip on it
I'll come back to it once make sure
there we go excellent okay good so who
here's based in the UK okay we all know
everyone is obsessed by house prices in
the UK everyone looks at them
everyone's State of Mind is based on if
house prices are rising or not and
depending on whether you're already in
the house market or not so what I wrote
is a simple application that basically
downloads prices that the UK government
publish every month every transaction
and lets you basically do some searching
so we're using things like blob storage
is your search table storage and so on
so I can do things like type in the name
of a town or a city or any keyword
really and we'll get some things like
find his typing I can it search and once
it wakes up then it will actually show
you some results in a table I can do
things like a sorting we get faceted
search on the left so that's the sort of
things that you get with Amazon when you
do a search and it shows you the
categories or the manufacturers on the
left we can also do things like click on
a little button and we'll get a pop up
you'll see you also get Google Maps
integration here
so pretty much the sort of things that
you would expect to see in a normal
application really an or web app I can
also do things like click on a postcode
on the right and what that will now do
is do a search based on locality so now
it's showing me results based on ones
that are closest to this one I just
clicked on click on the map and this is
just to show you that I can actually do
some programmatic work with this so
these pins are actually based on those
properties based on their longitude and
latitude and I can mouse over them and
it'll show me every property or sold how
much it was sold for and some can also
do things up here like I'm searching for
a postcode at the moment you see as I
type if it's an invalid postcode
actually get some real time red sort of
squiggly then it says not valid so I'm
somehow doing some kind of validation
here there's checking if it's a valid
postcode or not so let me go back here
and ask you now from application if I
was to say that was 100% F sharp who
would believe that it's not but 75% 50%
25% okay
so the answer is that's 92% that shot
the only file that's javascript is a web
pack config file everything else in
there is a shop there is not one line of
C shop there's no C there's no
JavaScript that we'd hand written and
there's one CSS file that's and one HTML
file there's a shell everything else in
that app was F sharp access to Azure
web development the view code all of it
so I'm not going to talk about this
today I'm doing a two hour workshop
tomorrow afternoon where we're going to
write an app that looks similar to that
in the afternoon so if you're interested
in finding out more you can come along
but for now just believe me when I say
that's true so given that I've hopefully
at least establish that you can write
end-to-end apps the real question now is
what is f sharp why would I want to use
it so f sharp first of all is a general
purpose programming language and I'll
come back to this time and time again
today to the point that you're gonna
hate me probably it runs on dotnet core
you can interoperate with C sharp and VB
so you can use all the new get packages
that are out there you can use all the
dotnet framework libraries you can talk
to sequel using system data or dapper or
any other libraries that are out there
it's a strongly typed language although
it doesn't look like it and it's
actually stronger than c-sharp in terms
of the type safety it's got a really
powerful compiler and a very very very
lightweight syntax this is the last
point though that it's functional first
and this will be the theme that we come
back to again and again today what do I
mean by functional first so when I ask
you about what is functional programming
oftentimes people will say these are the
sorts of things they're thinking of if I
was thought shewing c-sharp what are the
sorts of features you use today that you
would think of as functional programming
lambda expressions maybe pattern
matching like switch expressions the
idea of composer but
anything else mmm so in reality what it
really comes down to are these two
things here expressions and immutability
that's to my mind what the real core of
functional programming is and what we'll
try and do in the next 40 minutes or so
is look at really what that means how
that impacts on on that sharp and C
sharp and which one might be a better
fit for you
immutability
is just the idea that you create some
data and it never changes however ever
ever create a value you can't modify it
later on now at first glance that sounds
a bit weird we know that we always have
to change state but there are actually
ways of doing this in languages laughs
sharp to say you can take a copy of a
value make some changes and then get a
new value the new version of it but keep
the old one as well oftentimes people
talk about some of the benefits of that
like things like multi-threading and
things like that that are kind of not
everyone uses but if you think about it
even something as simple as passing a
value to a method may be that one of
your colleagues at bones
you know may be responsible for that
part of the system you might give them
an object they might change it without
you even realizing if you use a mutable
data that's no longer concern or how
many times have you written the code and
you've got a variable that's public or
are methods or remember there's public
and someone says I'll make it private
that way no one else can change it or
see it start working with a mutable data
who goes away you don't need to worry
about exposing values because no one can
change them anyway yep
yeah exactly like with strings but think
of this more as classes with all the
properties on them that you can't change
any of them
does anyone here know what an expression
is compared to a statement okay so
basically what this really means is the
idea is of they don't know what void is
in you know methods that return void so
with f-sharp there's no void every
method you call must return some
you must always get a result and that
has several implications but generally
what it tends to lead to is code that's
easier to test and if you ever doing
unit tests for example you have to
sometimes say I'm going to call a method
it doesn't return anything and the way
that I prove that this method is done
the right thing is I check some
properties on the class I check some
state of the object with expressions and
some pure functions the idea that you
just returned some data is really easy
you give some data to a function you get
some data back and then you check is at
the right value or not so this makes
things a lot simpler actually to reason
about Wireshark when F sharp first came
out this was the kind of tag line that
they started with and I think it was a
useful tactic because it was basically
they were targeting things like maths
and science problems and difficult
challenging things that maybe see shop
wasn't particular well suited to ten
fifteen years ago I would now say to
change it to say I want to solve simple
problems line of business apps
enterprise applications maybe maybe just
single page web apps but with really
simple code so this is not about F sharp
is only suitable for hard things but
it's a general language and you can use
for simple things as well so the sales
pitch that I often talk about is things
like lowest development costs so we do F
sharp 100% in what we do today we're
writing web apps windows services et L's
all those sorts of things we find it's
quicker for us to develop apps then it
would have been using other languages we
get fewer bugs our customers seem to be
happier refactoring code is pretty easy
and for me as a company owner and team
of developers we find that they're
happier because they are able to deliver
more for their customers more quickly
but this is really a key thing this
increased confidence I don't know about
you but I hate this feeling of releasing
applications on new versions of an app
and being really scared and nervous that
I've introduced bugs that I haven't
found out about maybe I didn't write
enough tests or maybe I try to put
something in and I'm really not sure
that it's going to be the right thing F
shop gives me a great deal more comfort
makes me actually enjoy what I'm doing
because I have the confidence that it's
the right thing whether or not I've been
doing the right thing for the customer
based on the requirements is a separate
issue but at least between me and the
keyboard and the computer that kind of
chance of things going Ori definitely
reduced also f-sharp has this notion of
scripting so if you come from a Python
background where you can get a rattle
and you can start doing interactive
programming f-sharp has that as a first
class sort of approach so you can start
doing scripting you don't need console
applications to test things out and
explore data you can just fire up a file
start typing an explorer domain really
really easily and also let you work
closely with customers so this is an
unusual one people tend not to think
about that f-sharp is really good at
domain modeling and it has a very
lightweight syntax that means it's easy
for non-technical people to actually
read what you're doing and I'll
hopefully show you that in a little bit
but the idea is that I've actually sat
down with customers opened up some empty
script file and said right let's try and
model your domain you have a customer
each customer has a set of orders each
order has ID the ID might sometimes be
there maybe it's nullable certain things
like this and you can actually go
through it with the customer and they
can build up this domain with you
interactively almost and you can try
things out very very quickly so it has a
very rapid feedback cycle customers
quite like does anyone heard of this
phrase the pitch success before okay
are any of you leading teams at a moment
running teams of developers or anything
like this you ever been on a project
where you've put in the kind of a
framework or a paradigm that you said
this is how we're going to do things
I've done a couple of examples I'm going
away for a few days maybe on holiday
maybe at another project and then you
come back and it's all just gone no
one's been able to follow what you said
or they didn't listen to you or it's
just you've come back how did you do
that I thought it was obvious what was
going on that's like the opposite of the
pit of success it's hard to do the right
thing and it's easy to go off this off
the part it's easy to do the wrong thing
so if you imagine that I this point up
here is going to be where things are
good and things down here are where
things go wrong it's really easy to go
wrong here doesn't need a bit of a wind
and this board is going to roll down as
hard
keep it in the stable point at the top
what we want to do is flip it and put it
into this pit of success where good
things happen here and to go out of
there to do the wrong thing is really
hard
that's where shock really shines it
allows you to encode rules in your code
so that actually your team will actually
get warnings and errors from the
compiler before they do the wrong thing
before they actually launch into
production in terms of history f-sharp
had a I think a few years ago it was in
a different position to today you know
we had this notion of things like
designer first tooling Visual Studio
you'd create form you drag on controls
and so on file new project we had code
generation so things like entity
framework for if you remember the early
days of that you had the drag-and-drop
designers WinForms all of those things
everything was closed source it really
didn't play well with that sharp because
Microsoft you know they couldn't invest
in all the same level of tooling that
c-sharp has into F sharp so you didn't
have the drag-and-drop designers for
WinForms you didn't have drag-and-drop
designers for entity framework so men
that F shucks would have had to carve
their own way there was a lot of tools
that people wrote that did similar
things that written from the ground up
nowadays in dotnet core it's all very
different you know we have this notion
of code first programming we've tried to
rely less on drag-and-drop designers we
have the dot SDK we don't really rule
nor allow and code gen anymore
everything is open-source this is
actually where F sharp has always been
more from a code first point of view
simple API is that are easy to
understand
command-line tooling with maybe some
gooeys on top but but but not relying on
that who here is actually using donate
core framework okay so to be fair F shot
works on both net core and dot natural
framework so there's no difference there
if you've got dotnet core you just have
to install the SDK and you've already
got that sharp so whether you know or
not you've already installed Microsoft
had definitely committed to have sharp
there was kind of a feeling a few years
ago that this wasn't the case but
they're really investing into it I've
got a growing team in America and in
Europe now four people working on the
tooling on the compiler team I think the
difference is really though that F sharp
community and the ecosystem
have a little bit more diversity I would
suggest and c-sharp echo system there
are certainly some tools and libraries
that are simply essentially the the
Microsoft MVC libraries or API Web API
that maybe wrappers on top of those
things so there are libraries like what
I showed you before with the Safe Search
app there's basically an f-sharp library
that sits on top of asp.net so we get
all the benefits of the security of the
performance improvements that Microsoft
you're introducing but we can still take
advantage of F sharp as a programming
language that we as developers interact
with spend a couple of minutes now on
just going through some sort of them
maybe some myths about a shop the one
I'm gonna say again and this will
probably be the last time is that it's a
general-purpose programming language a
lot of people think in the past that
when should I use a sharp you know I've
got to find that perfect use case for or
I've got to find some really hard
problem that makes F sharp worth the
effort of learning but if everyone if
you ever hear that phrase or if you
think to yourself and what's the area
that extract really shines where should
I really use it
the answer is programming really is that
simple so that's where F sharp is great
it's general-purpose language you can do
data access web apps with it
Windows services docker apps you name it
some of the things I hear sometimes it's
too hard or it's only for the maths and
science all the really complicated
things as I said before it's probably
was a useful tool for Microsoft early
days to differentiate F sharp from C
sharp but I think it's actually damaging
the language now it's not hard but it is
definitely different from C sharp and
what I'll talk about very shortly is
some of the distinctions and maybe
helping you understand why should you
look at F sharp rather than C sharp yeah
okay so the real challenge is to unlearn
what you've learned and this is where I
see people that are looking to F sharp
that come from C sharp this is the real
challenge they face is if you're
expecting to start looking at C sharp
and not have to
learn anything new or I want to still
write code the same way as I've done in
c-sharp you'll generally either be
disappointed frustrated or annoyed at
yourself for wasting time I've shopped a
different way of doing things the
question is whether it's a better fit
for you or not okay I wanted to look at
some examples in c-sharp and this is not
a character assassination of C shop the
language I'm a big fan of it but just to
illustrate some of the things about hard
and different imagine I'm a c-sharp to
developer will see sharp 3 I've come
from 2008 I've jumped forward in time
and looking at c-sharp 8 you know you
can do these range indexes in c-sharp
now you can basically say I've got a
string or an array and I want to take a
subset of it what items will this give
me back if I say 1 2 3 it's not going to
give me a to see B to D any ideas yeah
exactly
who thought it was beat C just one
person okay so this is because it's 0
basically it starts but it's 1 based
when it ends okay
I thought originally this was the length
but obviously not what about this one
hat 3 2 hat 0 anyone know what that is
yeah is this mean that C sharp is hard
or that maybe just not seen it before
I'd never seen this before but it
actually means go back 3 and then
starting from the back take the 0th
element interesting what about 5 5 we're
gonna get back e exactly nothing who
thought it was gonna get back nothing
it's about 10 to the audience right this
doesn't mean that C shop is hard but it
means that you've not been exposed to it
before not really sure what it's doing
does anyone know what this guy does
anyone seen this before
what do you think it does so this
basically says if object keys is null
run this code and assign it back to
object keys if it's not null don't do
anything so it's kind of a null coalesce
and an assignment in one I'd never seen
this before yeah
this means c-sharp is hard or bit
different something new here this was a
sample that came up when c-sharp 8 first
launched I had to think about this
really hard to understand what this code
does so we're calling a method called
get customers async which returns
asynchronously an enumerable set of
nullable customers we're going to go for
each of them and then we're going to
switch on each customer if the customer
is null give back null if the customer
is a tuple of null and some non null
string return back a string with mister
or missus second part otherwise get the
first element of this string and how do
I convert from customer to a tuple where
did that happen don't really know and
then at the end of it you get back a
nullable string as well I mean if you've
not done this before this to me is quite
hard to understand but again it's new
features in c-sharp that maybe we've not
been exposed to this is an older example
of C shop someone at Microsoft did this
code and they said oh this is really
cool this is like F sharp e got Elvis
null coalesce sorry ternary not equals
to so that was null coalesce turnery
other ternary and quote this is not what
F sharp is about so if anyone has told
you this is what F sharp is about is
putting together loads of crazy
operators not true this is to me
unreadable but maybe your your mileage
may vary it's another one I read from a
really well-known c-sharp blogger
community member does anyone look to see
shop eight default interfaces
people don't know what they do it's like
you can make abstract members on
interfaces now how do you use them when
do you use them I'm trying to read the
docs on this and I have no idea why I'm
looking for this is an experience
c-sharp dev then you don't want it them
his stuff that I find hard just so you
know that I'm not some sort of genius
mathematician I scrape through my
a-levels of maths and that was about the
extent of it anyone here do you share
point yeah I find SharePoint really hard
if any of you are like consultants in
SharePoint come to me afterwards I'd
love your help
JavaScript anyone here like JavaScript
in the way it handles equals lovely
that's hardly German grammar so I live
in Germany I'm still learning the
language German grammar is hard
especially if you come from English doc
net called versioning has anyone looked
at this SDK nonsense version 2 - 6 -
version 2 - 7 but it goes backwards from
to point to point 401 back to 2.2 109
how does this work
i sat alien yeah exactly
but yeah exactly so unusual I would say
that that's hard here are some reasons
that I have heard from people not
adopting a shop that that you may find
to be honest you don't know what
benefits offers don't have the time to
learn it that's probably the most common
one I hear or you company don't allow it
what these are really saying is
cost-benefit analysis
I can't invest the time and the cost and
the risk of trying something different
so I will stick with what we've got
that's an option that's totally
reasonable the tooling definitely ism is
going to c-sharp that's it's not bad but
it's knowing errors good a c-sharp some
people don't like the syntax I mean okay
fine
and this last one I can't get my head
around it and that really leads to to a
couple of slides later about the
features in a sharp and whether you
really grow or what it what it really
tries to push if you go the way I shop
lead you you're gonna love it if you try
and fight it you probably won't ever
actually doesn't have any of these
operators so all of those wonders so
before null coalesce
crazy assignment 1 the Elvis operator
turn Aries don't have any of them in
their shop so if anyone tells you the
f-sharp is this crazy language with
loads of operators it's not true the
only actual one it has that isn't in
c-sharp really is the pipeline and it's
really really simple but powerful pipe
operator so if we imagine here we've got
a function called ad which takes in two
numbers and when I assign that to answer
what you can also do is this so instead
of the 10 on the right I've pushed it to
the left and then I do this pipeline and
say pipe 10 into ad 5 right doesn't seem
that nice or that useful what about
something like this I want to add 5 x to
add 3 x 4 have you ever seen code like
this where you've got the bracket
bracket bracket going on forever or with
the pipe line it just becomes that yeah
and now it's 10 ad 5 x 2 + 3 x 4 easy
yeah and it's not just about math C
stuff I could do stuff like this load
customer 10 from the database validate
them generate a PDF email it to someone
so I can make a nice workflow now and
it's just pure simple functions that
we're going to compose together there's
actually a feature request in c-sharp to
add pipelines into the language it's
been going on for a while now it's
actually really hard because there are
certain features in F sharp the syntax
the way it handles things like curried
functions that you don't have in c-sharp
pulling something like the pipeline
doesn't really it doesn't really work
really doesn't work nicely so it's quite
a difficult one to to add a nice effect
it will never happen
we'll see so let's talk a little bit
about c-sharp and just that knowledge
you know first it's a great language
it's got loads of features fantastic
tooling anyone any language that you
compared to c-sharp and come up second
best in terms of tooling not even
without reach sharper even without it
scholars nowhere near at Java's no in
Eric C sharp has got fantastic tool in
visual studio it's got huge user base
you know rapidly growing feature set and
even if you look at the language
features you can see that it's been
getting more and more so-called
functional programming features you know
you have sort of c-sharp 3 with all
these guys C shop 7 holding tuples and
some basic pattern matching C shop 8 has
now got switch expressions as anyone
doing C shop mate today okay so have you
seen switch expressions yeah okay great
C shop my name is even gonna get more
you're going to get records probably
which we'll talk about in a minute and
maybe even union types which are both
from C F sharp look at people like this
John skeet is saying he's replacing a
load of switch statements with switch
expressions yeah he likes this stuff
he's applying more and more of it into
his own code null ability changes
another feature from F sharp from C
sharp 8 he's applying in I've got this
one from rich can't believe this is the
kind of the dotnet rocks top 3 3
features in c-sharp that will change the
way you write code this is not someone
saying that they will make code a bit
easier but actually changed the way you
write code these are the sorts of
fundamental changes happening in c-sharp
and they're basically equivalents or
very similar to features that are in F
sharp so then why should I bother using
F sharp at all yeah C shops getting all
these features many of them are similar
to F shop so we've got pattern matching
which people from F shop used to talk
about years ago you've now got something
similar in c-sharp to pools
you've even got nullable reference types
now why should you bother even investing
any time when you've got all the
features why not just wait a couple more
years eventually C shut will get even
more and this is now where it really
comes to the crux of it taken what half
an hour to get here
this is not about which language has the
most features or which one doesn't it's
about which language fits the way you
write code so if you see this now this
table here if there's one slide you want
to take away this is the one if you look
at this and you say I do everything on
the Left you might want to leave at that
point so if you like writing code that's
like statement oriented so everything is
voids you like mutating things by
default you right staple classes you do
imperative inheritance side-effect for
code F sharp is probably not going to be
a good fit for you
probably won't be if on the other hand
you like doing things with expression so
you've tried switch expressions you like
them you're doing local functions maybe
lambda expressions things like that if
you've tried doing a mutable code data
structures things like that or records a
shot might be a nicer fit
they don't one here doing linked yeah if
you like that sort of way of programming
f-sharp is like that's the default way
of writing code and composing everything
and reach through composition rather
than inheritance so if you rather than
doing inheriting you're taking
interfaces implementing them building
them together you might find actually
the F shop is a nice way of doing things
is no.100 this thing called like single
responsibility principle this SRP so
what you end up doing with with this
principle of a she says one your classes
should do one thing one thing I like and
if you take that to its logical sort of
conclusion every every class should only
have one method then it does one thing
well if that's what you're saying you
may as well just pass functions around
in which case f-sharp is actually a
natural way of doing things because you
just pass functions around you don't
pass objects around and this comes back
to it again what I said earlier where I
said it's not about how many features of
language has its that it has the right
blend of features so things like um
implicit conversions mutability
references and those features sort of
push against other ones so when I talk
about pipelines earlier on and said
people might want to add that into
c-sharp you can't really do it easily
because pipelines needs another feature
of f-sharp called curried functions and
curried function doesn't work if you
have method overloading so you're almost
like it's like you've gone down one path
you can't really Conde breaking changes
in c-sharp so you can't stop how things
work so the only option is to bring in
somehow cut down versions of these
features there's nothing else you can
really do to give you an idea of some of
the things you would lose if you move to
have sharp these are all the things you
either can't do or a difficult to do so
you can't do things like protected you
can't create an object and assign half
of it you have to assign everything
upfront
on the one hand that might be a bit
annoying you know what what if I don't
know what the values are up front there
are ways around that
excuse me on the other hand it means if
you deal with that up front you don't
have an issue later on of accessing some
value and it's null can't happen
[Music]
cyclical references so people hate this
enough shot when they first come to it
you cannot access a value unless it's
already been defined and you can't
access any types unless they have
already been declared further up in the
project so it's actually has this kind
of downward facing dependency so why
would I want to do that well firstly it
means things are quite simple if you
want to know where your dependencies
aren't you just look upwards everything
the bottom is the top level of the end
of your file and everything at the top
is the low level parts of your code
effectively they can't see anything else
and it also stops you doing spaghetti
code where you have a that calls be the
call see the calls be the calls a yeah
it does everything follows in one
direction so the things you can do is
curried functions which I'll show you
with a quick demo later on pipelines
proper type inference so does anyone
here using var that's all yeah so an
f-sharp basically everything can be var
you don't have to put in type
declarations basically anywhere the
compiler will figure it all out for you
nine times out of ten so you can write
entire apps declare your types write
functions you don't have to put in any
type declarations which really is a
time-saver and a very lightweight syntax
so let's go back here in terms of that
the object side of F sharp it does have
it because it runs on top of dotnet so
it needs to be able to do classes and
interfaces to run with the rest of map
but the only parts that you'll normally
use are things like stateless objects
you won't really make mutable objects
you might use interfaces probably won't
use mutable data or events and you
definitely won't use inheritance on
nulls or overloads these are things like
if they dare to you you probably will
find it quite difficult or it might be
that the challenge to start looking at F
sharp these are I think the key sort of
changes for a shop
you learn to trust the compiler what do
I mean by that rather than writing code
and thinking about it all yourself
you tend to be a bit lazy if I'm honest
I get quite lazy when I'm writing a shot
because I basically write some types
I'll write some functions and then I
just wait for the warnings and the
errors in the compiler normally errors
you fix the errors carry on these form
or you fix the errors you carry on you
run the code nine times out of 10 it
works first time the difference is you
spend a bit more time writing the code
but you don't spend much time debugging
because normally you fix the problems
upfront the compiler will catch a lot
more errands and I'll show you a quick
demo at the end if we've got time that
will just sort of illustrate how that
works I'm going to skip through some of
these I sort of talked about this
already expressions that they let you
write code more more succinctly the
catch more bugs I'm going to give you an
example here this is some C sharp this
is a function that it's going to
describe someone's age I'm going to pass
in the age and I'm going to say if the
age is less than 18 set the description
to child otherwise sets it to adult and
then write out you know hello you are a
child or an adult there are a couple of
bugs in here I've sneaky left in can you
see any of them taken yeah that's one
there's another one
excellent so there's that so I've
assigned it to the wrong value so if
it's 65 it's gonna print out adult you
are a nothing and as you also pointed
out I've missed out the else case now
see shop can't tell me about this it's
not the C sharp is of bad languages this
notion of statements the compiler
doesn't understand that there's some
relationship between all these different
cases it just knows if the age is 18 do
something otherwise if it's 65 do
something else
it doesn't realize there's this
relationship between the two branches
you can't do this in c-sharp you split
it into a method that does that check
and now you'll actually get a proper
compiler support here if I miss out this
last case the compiler will give me an
error it'll say you can't miss the
so you have to provide a default value
if you don't pass into those two and
it's impossible for me to assign to the
wrong guy age description or greeting
because it's all coming in one place
it's this atomic action so we've already
solved two bugs now you might look at
this and think now I'll never do that
imagine a team with maybe eight
developers some genius some seniors
writing hundreds and thousands of lines
of code in a shop this is exactly how
things work by default so if else is
actually an expression so I can say let
age description equals if age is less
than 18 then child if it's less than 65
then adult else
OAP so that that sort of built into the
language so if you find yourself writing
code like this it's kind of that's how
things work there's anyone looking there
are a couple of people here that said
they're using switch expressions so this
is something in c-sharp eight you had
switch number before where we could say
if the number is 1 then output as hello
break if it's 2 then output equals this
blah blah blah and FMC shop eight you
can now do this you can say I want to
switch on the number if one then hello
if 2 then 3 bar 3 goodbye otherwise
default and it all gets assigned to
output so this is like distilling the
difference between a statement or four
statements in this case and one
expression all gets assigned to a single
value and an F shop is exactly the same
syntax is a bit different but it's again
match number with one goes to hello two
goes to fubar and so on so if you're
using things like this and c-sharp a and
you think this is awesome in F sharp
this is the default way of working this
is like there is no switch statement
everything is is a pattern match
expression said I'm doing async await
sort of stuff in c-sharp today have you
ever done this before where you create
an async method and you forgot to await
some task returning method you get a
warning here it's quite nice it says
because this call is not a weighted blah
blah blah consider applying the async
operator so the compiler is actually
good here it knows that you've forgotten
to do in a weight and it gives you a
warning and it know
is that because this function returns
tasks of tea yep great unfortunately it
doesn't do it anywhere else so here I've
got a method it's returning a string
I've forgotten to assign it though I'm
just calling it compiler is not going to
warn me here because in c-sharp all the
defaults are around statements it
doesn't assume that you're writing code
to return values whereas an f-sharp you
get a warning here it says hang on you
called this function tech that gives
back text and not signed it anywhere the
result of this has type string and it's
implicitly ignored so it's actually
warning you there's some result you're
ignoring it please do something so
either I could assign it to a value or I
can do this ignore and I actually am
saying to the compiler I know it returns
something ignore what it's giving back
I'm telling you I know better
so if you're writing code that is
normally sort of returning values that
you throw away you'll probably find this
really annoying you have to put ignore
everywhere but if you want that
protection because you're writing code
that returns values and you want to work
with values that's often much better fit
because it will tell you when you've
done things wrong another thing you
don't have void in F sharp so you can't
do this in c-sharp I can't call a method
that returns void and assign it to
result you get an error in that shop you
can actually do that because we have
this thing called unit which is actually
an object it's actually a thing that you
can throw around then you can pass
around to other types and other values
so here I can actually say let result
equals print my name and I'll actually
assign it to unit why is this important
have you ever done anything with tasks
and you've got tasks of T and the
non-generic
task guy so you've got two versions with
f-sharp you don't need that there's just
one type of task if you don't return any
value it's just tasks of unit so
straight away everything gets simpler in
that regard right working with nulls
anyone doing anything with nominal
ability in c-sharp aims today I look at
it so this is how it works you put this
question mark at the end and now the
compiler is going to give me a warning
that says string might be null and I'm
assigning it to a non null non nullable
learn
you can't you shouldn't be doing this
you can override this you just put an
exclamation mark at the end and then it
turns off the compiler check not so fond
of that see in that trap you can't do
this that's a completely different type
this thing called string option is
basically saying the string might be
there but it might not be there
that's like saying in in c-sharp sinus
Strait destroying the value one two
three to a string you can't do it
they're completely incompatible yeah
c-sharp also introduces this thing
called flow analysis so if I pass in
this nullable string and I do if it's
not null then he'll let me check it
because he knows I've done a null check
but otherwise outside of that he knows
it's still non nullable right nice
interesting but it's also confusing adds
some complexity not only to the language
but also to you as developers what if
you're doing something a bit more than
just this you're calling another method
that's doing the check then you've now
got to think well what if that one does
it how does where does the check happen
and so on in F sharp there's no such
thing as this flow analysis you
basically take in a string and even if I
check if it's null or not that type
there that text is always optional
you're not allowed to just blindly do
dot and access a variable value that
might be missing you can't do it how do
we do it in that shop we have this thing
called pattern matching so I can say
match the text with if it's some text
then I'm allowed to check it otherwise
it's nothing
give a default value instead you know so
in this case now the compiler has made
it impossible for me to accidentally dot
into it we'd literally can't have null
references with this sort of approach
you can get them in corner cases but
basically if you're writing normal F
shop code you won't get no references
just to sort of sum up what I'm really
been getting it for the last ten twenty
minutes or so is you have all these
corner cases in a Charlotte NC shop
where async await where you have things
like this extra checking that you get me
don't have everywhere else if something
don't really have that you have this
thing called void which is
a hole in the type system in C sharp F
sharp doesn't exist no such thing as
implicit type conversions you can't go
from into flight without an actual
proper type check and a conversion and
you don't have any of these crazy
operators in F sharp it's just basic
functions basic methods basic types you
learn these sort of fundamental rules
and then everything just works really is
so it's it's a very different approach
rather than having custom language
support for different use cases air
shops approaches rather we have a
general set of features that apply to
all of these different cases so once you
learned them you can basically do
everything and this is the last part
we'll talk about and I'll do a bit of a
little bit of scripting after this just
so you can see the kind of the
development sort of cycle and how it
applies so it's the simple domain
modeling exercise right we have a
customer object every customer can be
contacted in one of several ways email
post or telephone one of not all of them
one-off and all of those you can contact
the customer by email or post or
telephone how do you model this version
one who would do this I'll create a
class called customer and I'll put the
fields on there across all of those so I
have a telephone number address line one
dress line two postcode and email
address so you've got one class with all
the fields on it who would do that
anyone okay you probably do something
like this you have a method called
contact it will say if the telephone
number isn't null this guy must be a
telephone customer and I'll call it if
the address line one isn't null this
must be a postal customer therefore a
post it otherwise it must be an email
address you'll get what I'm doing here
nothing too crazy why wouldn't you want
to do this what's wrong with this
approach
yeah could all be now brilliant anything
else yeah exactly
cool so forget you might have just the
dress line one populated but what two of
the postcode and if you look at this
it's not clear you can't look at this
class and understand the business rule
we're trying to encode we're trying to
say only one of these can be populated
at any one time you can't know that from
this what about if we said iron ore what
we'll do we'll have an enum that will
add on to the class that will then say
contact method is telephone or address
or email address and then we'll just add
it to these and then we'll check first
so we'll say that and all that will say
check the contact method if it's
telephone then I'm going to call the
telephone number if that method that
value is address then I'll do this if
it's email address then do that anyone
will do this yeah it seems reasonable
still got the same sort of issue that
haven't you in that there's nothing to
stop someone looking at this class
setting this value to telephone but
leaving that null and filling in those
ones but we can't really solve it to be
honest easily except you can in c-sharp
who would do this I'll make an abstract
class called contact method and then
I'll have a telephone subclass and
address subclass and an email subclass
and then I'll use polymorphism I'll put
my contact method on there and I have a
void polymorphic method called contact
who would do that
anyone mm-hmm exactly yeah all with
interfaces okay great so we've now about
this certain thing we've got I have an
interface and say eye contact method
same sort of thing really way and then
you probably have a factory and probably
some sort of strategy pattern to go
through it right we're already now into
the worlds of design patterns okay fine
let's have a look how this would look in
F sharp and you've waited probably forty
minutes for me to actually type anything
now we'll do some code so I'm going to
fire up visual studio and let's actually
type it from scratch so let's remove
this guy right so the first thing I want
to do is model my customer is that
okay the back yeah okay good so let's
start by creating a customer object with
a type customer equals name string let's
say they've got an age as well and then
I'm going to say contact method what do
I put here right don't really know this
is gonna have the bits whether it's
telephone email or post so what we're
going to do is create what's called a
union type method
it's either that's what that pipe means
we'll say it's telephone of number so
telephone number which can it's either a
telephone which contains a number is its
data or it's an email address of address
which is a string or postal of and I'm
gonna create a record in line I'll say
line one there's a string line two is a
string or postcode it's a string or
let's see what's going on there yep okay
and now I can go back here then I can
say contact method so there's my record
so let's create and one of these see
what it looks like so let's create a
customer which we're gonna call Isaac
name is Isaac and if that'll do a little
online so age equals forty contact
method equals let's do a telephone one
two three okay what about done wrong
there it's too big for an integer so
what this is saying is now I've created
a record interestingly if I'm not
actually told that what type this is
I've not said here this is a record of
type customer and if I mouse over this
guy he knows it's a customer how does
the compiler know that because he's
looked above in the scope of the entire
app and he said well the only time
how's those fields is customer therefore
this must be a customer and because in
that shop you can't have circular
references it can't be something that's
been declared later it's only stuff
that's already been declared so you're
starting to see some of the benefits you
get by having some of these other
constraints now I'm going to write my
contact method which is going to take in
a customer so this is the guy that's
going to know whether to say hello
whether to call them whether to send an
email whatever in fact just before I do
that I'll just show you one of the nice
features is this roughly when we get an
f-sharp
so let's pin that to the right so whoa
that's quite big that's just that that's
right good so what this thing on the
right is does anyone use like um the
immediate window and see shot when
you're running this is like an immediate
window buts there while you're typing in
code while you're editing while you're
actually creating codes so I've actually
just sort of executed it and I can even
send a value in so I can send Issac on
and now it's actually created that down
the bottom I can do some things now I
can say well let's have a look at
Isaac's name I like that and then I get
down at the bottom Isaac so you can
imagine I can actually start to explore
this create some types let's create a
function see if it works or not so I'm
going to create my function called
contact and I'm gonna say match customer
doctor contact method with so I wanted
to spend depending on what type of
contact method I've got I want to do
different logic good so we'll say if
it's a telephone number I want to print
the text calling number so this guy here
represents the telephone number that I
entered before it's like unwrapping it
or I could say if it's a email address
let's go back that okay interestingly
now if I mouse over can you see that
green squiggly it's saying that I forgot
to do postal I haven't dealt with that
yet so the compiler is actually guiding
me now to do the right thing so let's
fill in postal I'm just going to go on
and any lines address dot y1 address dot
line to address doctor postal code
another interesting thing if I mouse
over customer he again knows that that's
of type customer how does he know that
because I've used the field called
contact method that's the only record in
scope that's got a field called contact
method therefore this must be a customer
so you can then you can just put in a
type annotation so then something like
this yeah yeah absolutely it will take
the first one that's been declared then
and then you can say actually I know
better
it's this guy oh if you start using more
properties he'll against our there's
only these ones that could use all of
them it must be done also notice that
there's no return type here I've not had
to specify it but I can see there look
this guy contact says give me a customer
I'll give you back a string
let's try it out so I've got my contact
function I can now say contact Isaac yep
so now I've actually just explored I
didn't need a console app didn't need a
web project I just fired up a file try
to experiment let's look at it a
slightly more complex example very very
quickly let's assume that telephone I
said actually I need to now add in a
region like a country code beforehand
how would I do that so let's say it's
either UK or foreign and if it's forum
we're gonna have a pre dial code which
is an int so I've created this type now
I'm gonna add it on to telephone so I
can say write telephone is now the
combination of country and the phone
number yeah
straightway get an arrow down here so I
have to add in that works again but
let's say I wanted to be a bit smarter I
wanted to have a specific method a
specific handler for UK numbers
different message that's easy I can say
if it's UK and a number calling home and
let's just fix this
it's okay look I get another compiler
warning I handled UK by forgotten to
handle foreign please fix it let's let's
go fix that one let's be a bit of a
cheat and we'll say foreign one so only
ones that have foreign number one with
no special you for nine then I can say
calling Germany like an heiress saying
you didn't handle foreign zero so we'll
keep going until it's exhausted all the
cases where in my case I could just be
lazy and say well if it's some foreign I
don't care what code always fall into
this case so it lets you actually model
your domain and then pro sort of
progressively capture all the different
cases upfront right where's the clicker
almost at a time so that's good showing
you that I'm going to show you that I
want to show you this so to me this is
where sharp strengths are and now I've
only shown you sort of the high level
bits of it one this idea that you trust
your code because it uses things like
expressions and immutability which we've
seen already how that can resolve
certain bugs and also these some types
or union types as you just saw that's
something that currently you can't do in
c-sharp the idea that something is one
of a number of cases that's really
nicely an F sharp you get to feel
productive you've got the rappelled that
I showed you very very briefly type
inference again I showed you briefly
this really nice lightweight syntax it's
a community layered open-source there's
commercial support Microsoft are backing
it so you have that safety net and also
you press the platform so cross-platform
if using that core you can use on Linux
you can use on Mac you can use some
Windows you have a huge ecosystem if
you're on dotnet already you are not
giving up anything in terms of libraries
by moving to a shop or trying it out you
can use basically every existing library
you've got that core you've already got
F sharp if you've got that framework and
Visual Studio 99% at the time you'll
already have F sharp installed you've
got this Visual Studio users here I've
seen Rider anyone
code yeah all of those work so no
problems how do you start so I give
people three different ways one is what
I call logic islands let's say you've
got some bit of business logic in your
code in your app maybe it's not going to
the database it's just something you
want to model and run some business
rules on just try it in F sharp you can
call that from C sharp it just looks
like a static class you won't notice any
difference
try vertical slice take one part of your
app and try and go end-to-end from start
to finish or horizontal tier I'll do all
my business logic in F sharp all my data
access or my validation rules do it with
more than one person now if you want to
try it in your company today don't do it
on your own because you will be known as
the F sharp weirdo basically don't do
that get a couple of people it's much
easier than to run with it even if you
just do one hour a week or half an hour
a week even it's not a lot of time we do
something like this and our company
where we just say we allocate once a
week or even once a day every morning or
at lunch time or just after lunch 15 20
minutes to learn something new it's a
habit you build in within a month you'll
be fine how do you learn it though you
can work with a coach like myself you
could hire an experienced a shop
developer could buy a book I might
happen to to have one here go to a
meet-up anyone here in London there's
like huge well there's a big F shot
meetup here runs like once a month you
can go meet people there talk to them
find out port an existing module or app
this is probably the best way I would
recommend if it's something you already
know
you know the domain you know how it
works try and model it in F sharp try
and write the business rules in it you
already know how it should work
see if you can transport that across the
official website is F sharp the org
there's some good starting resources
there's a slack channel there's also
just running now from f shop the org the
mentorship program which is free you get
basically assigned and experience a shop
developer they'll spend one hour a week
with you doesn't cost anything just have
to register there's also a forum forms a
shop or Twitter a shop this is my book
get programming with that sharp it's a
very very practical guide I mean what I
went through today is probably the depth
of
of the technical side of things it's
basically just how do I write line of
business proper applications in f-sharp
how do I use new gap how do I work with
databases WPF that sort of thing how do
you convince your boss if you do try it
and you find well I can't really
convince anyone
don't use technical features don't go to
your boss and talk about scrum related
unions or type inference it doesn't wash
it and it shouldn't wash with you guys
either if I'm talking about it now what
you do want to talk about I think like
quicker time to market less bugs happier
developers this is so important for me I
mean you've got a team of people working
with you
f-sharp makes them happier at least in
my experience and the fact that there
are companies that do commercial support
even if you don't need it tell your boss
there are companies out there they've
got those and safety net then if you do
want to try it and you want to go and
have a look at F sharp I would challenge
you to spend 30 minutes just reading up
on air shop just look on a website won't
cost you much get a book make a plan put
in place the progress you know a habit
every day 15 minutes for the next month
I'll try it do a.net anew you can do dot
net a new console - Lang F sharp and
you'll have a national path it's really
that easy nowadays and dotnet core
pulling up on modules dying using it
obviously that last bit might be a bit
more challenging depending on your
experience but it really is doable
so with that thank you very much
appreciate your patience we've got time
for any questions if there are any no
not even one okay well apart from the Y
Mona is
yeah that's why that's why I put that
there but seriously if you're interested
please contact me I've got some cards
we'd obviously be interested in in there
your thoughts and yeah thank you
[Music]